hello the internet i'm gav welcome to
the slo-mo guy
a lot of the videos i try and make are
around familiar subjects
something you may have seen a few times
or even used but then you get to see it
in slow-mo
this video is nothing like that it's
about a very specific piece of lab
equipment
called an ultrasonic homogenizer or a
sonicator as it's sometimes known
there's a bunch of applications for this
but one of the main ones is
you can use it to mix liquids that
wouldn't usually mix
like oil and water for example and how
it does it
is by vibrating this tip
this little metal tip tens of thousands
of times
per second this one will vibrate up and
down
just slightly about 30 000 times
in a single second and we're going to
see what that looks like in slow-mo
obviously because it's 30
000 times a second if i use the regular
phantom flex 4k
we're limited to a thousand frames a
second in 4k which means it will be
moving
30 times up and down in a single frame
that's no good we do need to go faster
we ideally need to be at frame rates
higher than 30 000 frames a second a lot
of the time in an actual science lab
you'll see these in their own little
enclosures with a door but um this isn't
as fancy this is the cheapest one i
could find that it didn't come with any
of that so we're just going to
stick it in this little clamp that i may
or may not have stolen
from the set of planet slo-mo as you
know on this channel for 90
of the videos we use the phantom flex 4k
which is a very lovely 4k image a
thousand frames a second but when we
need to go faster than that
we typically use one of the v series
cameras is the 2511
supplied by destin which is a science
camera much lower resolution
but much faster frame rate okay let's
start with just a simple glass of water
just to see its effects on the liquid
got a macro lens on so we'll get really
close to the tip i'm going to start
full resolution which will give us 28
500 frames a second
oh so loud
oh this is interesting yeah so what
we're seeing here is cavitation bubbles
basically the sonicator is moving so
fast
and so frequently that it's just tearing
these little voids in the water where a
bubble forms but there's not actually
air in there it's just a gap in the
water
and then the forces opposing that cause
it to collapse in
but because the sonicator is moving so
fast they're constantly opening and
closing
to create these shock waves all
throughout the liquid and every time
one of these bubbles implodes it also
creates heat
and it seems to be causing the liquid to
flow straight down from the middle
and then around the side so i think if
we do this again with oil on the top
we'll see the oil get sent down
the probe so here i'm adding some
vegetable oil quite a
quite a large serving but this should
mix them together into a sort of
emulsion
[Music]
oh yes you can see the the flow it
creates
all of the bashed liquid goes straight
down the middle
of the tip so all the oil
is then drawn in to fill that void so it
actually gets mixed
down the probe and then spreads out to
the sides
you can see here that the oil is sending
the tip out of focus but you can see
here it's smashing the oil into tiny
particles
okay we've seen what it does submerged
in liquid now i just want to see what it
does to a single drop
balanced on the top i'll film this about
40 000 frames a second
instantly vaporized just smashed into a
million pieces
it even got the stuff that i'd spilled
further down and it collected in the
base of the sonicator head
wow
it looks so big it scales it up so much
this is like this is like a scaled down
version of what the scarecrow was trying
to do
in batman begins where he's trying to
use the ultrasonic weapon to
vaporize all the city's water just
absolutely aerosolizes all of it
makes it completely breathable
i can tell because of the way the camera
can't decide what
color to make them some of these
droplets are smaller
than a single pixel on the sensor
and it looks as though as the sonicator
is moving up and down the downward
movement
is drawing the air in to it so that as
the droplets are coming back around
they're getting sucked back on and just
punched even smaller
all right let's just do one obscenely
fast so we can actually see the proper
movement
of the sonicator head we won't see much
in terms of detail here
because we're not even 400 pixels wide
on this resolution but we do have
171 000 frames a second
and i need so much light for this shot
that even just slightly offsetting my
backlight
looks completely pitch black so the only
way i can see anything
is by shining the light directly in the
lens hole this
the exposure time is so low that the
light refracting through the droplet
isn't even bright enough
okay i'm talking to you now from the
edit as we analyze this clip i want to
find out how long it takes
for the sonicator to do a full up down
cycle
so i'm just going to speed it on a
little bit here so we can see it if we
do the mass
and divide one second by 30 000
it gives us 0.000033 of a second
so if i pull up the absolute time here
we should be able to look at time
directly for the answer instead of using
a calculator firstly pay attention to
how slowly the second is ticking by
even our milliseconds are ticking by
painfully slowly the speed so we're
mainly looking in the microsecond
area i'm now going to slow the footage
down in post to about 10 percent giving
us the equivalent
of almost 2 million frames a second
playback
and then we'll pick an arbitrary up and
down cycle
and just pay close attention to the time
yeah so that is that's very close that's
the difference
that's point zero zero zero zero
three five uh as opposed to what we
calculated there with the point zero
zero zero
three three so slightly slower than 30
kilohertz
but uh definitely in that ballpark
interestingly there are some forms of
humidifiers you can buy which use
ultrasonic tech like this to smash water
up and
get it in the air it's one way of
humidifying a room
doing it one drop at a time though not
recommended it will take you
much much longer to increase your
relative humidity
i now want to learn whether an apple
enjoys being
vibrated at a very fine point at 30
kilohertz
burning it whoops
sonicated the phantom there a little bit
it seems to be causing
such tiny concentrated pockets of heat
that the apple is just immediately
burning at that point
it's crazy that if my frame rate is
below the frequency of the
sonicare it just looks like a blur
because it's moving back and forth so
many times
the picture of it is being taken a
different spot each time so it just
looks like a
blurry slow thing where it's actually a
supremely fast
punchy thing this is bizarre i'm not
sure whether this is creating any
cavitation bubbles in
the liquid of the apple or whether it's
just sheer friction
we should try this on something that
doesn't have any moisture in it
also seems to be able to cook its way
through wood
wow
there's no way i'm not wrecking this
thing
this is just the friction we're dealing
with this could potentially be used as a
it's a fire starter i bet you could get
an ember if it's if it's actually
causing this wood to smoke
this thing's a fire hazard will it go
through
the cloth of my lab coat okay three two
one
up immediately absolutely no resistance
at all
i'm gonna try an old t-shirt
i can find where this is
all right i've blocked your view of that
sorry about that um
if you had to see it on slow-mo though
yeah then one of when one of the holes
gets big enough
the whole thing just smashes through
well there we have it some very
interesting and rather bizarre footage
of the intended use and also some
unintended use of an ultrasonic
homogenizer
i may have wrecked it it is looking
slightly charred at the end now
um i mean i don't really plan on using
it again
i'll stick it in a box just in case
though if you can think of any other lab
equipment
that would be very interesting to see
how it works in slow-mo let me know in
the comments
i might be able to get my hands on some
and do another one of these
hopefully you enjoyed that video if you
want to be alerted to new slo-mo's
make sure you subscribe and hit the old
bell and give it a like if you liked it
if you didn't
i am incredibly sorry hopefully you'll
like the next one
see you next time